a special ffp3 face mask
that is lars fisher's most important
protection
the 43 year old was born with an illness
called fraser syndrome and had a kidney
transplant
covid19 poses an acute danger to his
life every time he leaves the house he
takes a risk
it's most immaculate i always have to be
lucky the virus only has to be lucky
once
if i then think about the hospitals
which are filling up the fact that i
can't be properly cared for can't be
visited what if i get seriously ill
these are thoughts that go through my
head i'm
done drinking coffee not really
the coronavirus vaccinations are not
having their full effect on him
since his transplant lars fisher has
been taking immunosuppressive medication
every day to prevent his body from
rejecting the organ
after the first two vaccinations i had
very very few antibodies and only the
ones that don't protect you
now i've had four doses and i'm still
waiting for the results but i'm afraid
it still doesn't look very good
lars fisher knows that compared to many
other people with disabilities he has
made it through the pandemic relatively
well so far
this is also due to his profession he is
a science journalist with a focus on
infectious diseases he has been able to
put his specialist knowledge about
infectious diseases to good use over the
last two years
that's why i own the vibes in the office
it was also an incredibly exciting time
for me professionally
because i was one of the very few
journalists in germany who really knew
something about pandemics and that was
something that gave me strength that
ultimately also carried me
along lars fisher expects to get
infected with covid19 at some point but
he hopes that by then a drug will be
available to treat him well
here's a look at some other developments
in the coronavirus pandemic the world
health organization is calling on
wealthy countries to fill a 23 billion
dollar funding gap to help poorer
countries fight the coronavirus the who
says unequal access to tests treatments
vaccines and protective equipment risks
prolonging the pandemic
hong kong says it's
recorded its first possible covet linked
death in five months despite a zero
covered policy the city has reported
hundreds of new infections in recent
days and the u.s state of new york will
drop its indoor mask mandate for most
public places starting wednesday the new
york times reports
the state's governor intends to let the
mandate expire rather than renew it the
paper said